[Applause]
[Music]
i see you
hello hello again ladies and gentlemen
here at the garmadi team in brussels and
out there online joining us from
wherever you are in the world
welcome to the official opening of the
new european bauhaus festival
in the next four days expertise will be
shared innovative ideas will be
presented and artists will show their
work
all over brussels but also in many other
places in europe and beyond
the new european bauhaus festival i've
said this before it's like an agora
where people citizens politicians
artists and scientists alike
meet
discuss
and inspire each other
all that with the aim to create a
sustainable
beautiful world together in a spirit of
the original bauhaus
of over one century ago
however this festival takes place while
a war is raging on european soil it is
not something that will be ignored
in the next few days on the contrary i
would say
it begs
to define all the clearer
the new european bauhaus's relevance
and what it should be about
now as i said the festival does take
place all over europe and other european
countries not only in brussels so in the
next hour we will be linking up
to people in other eu member states to
find out
what they are showcasing
and what they have organized in the
context of the new european bauhaus and
what they want to contribute
from their perspective and from their
realities
however
first we link up to rome that's where
ursula von der lion european commission
president is and the world renowned
architect francis kerry they will join
us from rome
led by
under in the capable hands of my
colleague monica monica greetings from
brussels ciao tutti
la in roma
chanelis good morning
[Applause]
such a pleasure
seeing you there in brussels it's a
great european morning this morning
where you we are able to connect to
share ideas to share thoughts and
discussions as you mentioned president
montgomery media francisca is here i
think in a few moments we will be able
to listen their visions and perspectives
so important especially in this
moment which is a very difficult moment
as you mentioned but first of all
lying to you annalise starting from
process again lying is yours
and we will be seeing more of you and
your guests in a moment but indeed
first of all as i said we will be going
around some european cities where people
have put a lot of effort into creating
their vision on the new european bauhaus
project so let's start first to denmark
to jens hansen's greetings from brussels
yes
welcome to the singer
it's a beautiful day here in helsinki
denmark the city of hamlet's castle
chromebook
in these days we have together with our
swedish partners filled the streets with
performers from all over europe to
discuss sustainability of the arts
as a theater and a festival it's urgent
and necessary for us to pose the
important question what we can do to
keep our european international
relations with artists in a sustainable
way the future calls for green festivals
green theater at green europe and we
want to be part of that at the moment we
are doing a
creative europe from europe project here
called in instant visit and slo-mo and i
might give you a little peek of what is
going on although they are running away
from me but that's it from denmark thank
you very much
thank you jens thank you so much and on
to verena verena is in
austria verena ringler hello from
brussels
chris got from innsbruck i'm varena
wrangler of european agora european
green deal and at more than 2000 meters
above sea level high in the clouds we
stage a celebration of soil seeds and
our human senses
mountain peaks like that one
help us to see things in perspective and
to understand that every cubic meter of
healthy living soil is the treasure for
humanity
soil is the new gold
one tablespoon of it has more organisms
than there are people on earth
it absorbs co2 it gives us food and
filtered water and of course beauty
we all love
flowers
so
here melanie who advocates a european
youth lab on soil and thomas who
oversees one of the world's two oldest
genetic street banks tyrol seed bank is
a hundred years old
meet stephanie who envisions hundreds of
citizen biotops in rural europe and
architect anna herringer who says soils
from sweden to spain give us mud
re-housing material of tomorrow
we of agora european green deal want
every person to discover their real gold
under our feet
thank you so much verena for broadening
our horizons literally today and for
joining us thank you so much all of you
there in austria and on to estonia there
uh anna tomingas will tell us more about
what they have in store anna greetings
from brussels
i am anna i'm the manager of timber
architecture research center box at the
estonian academy of arts
located in italy in estonia
pak as a research
center
deals with three major topics
the green revolution
in construction
the digital revolution
in the industry
and new methods of
designing
prefabricated and modular wooden
buildings
today we are connecting from acrulic
water
which is an old production plant
here in tallinn
dating back to the 19th century
and
it will go under development
[Music]
in a few years and over 12 000
apartments will be built here
and so
over the past semester our
architecture students
have been working on solutions uh for
apartment buildings uh in this quarter
and today
a pop-up exhibition especially uh
organized
for the
new european house festival
called the recruiting
reconstruction
constructing spatial
culture will be opened
we have as you can see eight different
studies here with project descriptions
and
modules
the studio's objective was to develop
flexible architecture from sustainable
materials based on digital design and
fabrication but we were looking
at possible ways of living together
beyond the usual
apartment association
ownership model
so
we welcome you here
in tallinn
and please come and visit us at the
estonian academy of arts thank you for
having us
thank you
for talking to us from tallinn from a
location venue that looks a bit like the
garmari team if you ask me and on to
helen fronius in germany hi helene i'm
looking forward to uh hearing what you
have in store for us greetings from
brussels to youtube
hello us deutschland this is first yuta
speaking to you from weimar in germany
the original bauhaus was founded here in
our main building of bauhaus university
weimar by walter gropius in 1919
at that time bauhaus students were
seeking a socially inclusive and
aesthetic way of life
not so much different from today
in 2022 we add a more sustainable way of
arriving
for this aim we our four faculties
architecture and urbanism civil
engineering arts and design and media
work together on an interdisciplinary
basis
you see we are an institution which
embraces its role as a partner in the
new european bauhaus
now helen is pleased to tell you about
our first festival event
thank you very much tomorrow we will
have a full day of hands-on workshops
and lively discussions here at the
university itself and also in the town
of wymar where we will be engaging with
its citizens about how to make where we
live more sustainable how can we work
towards a future where neighborhoods
serve their diverse communities whilst
also contributing towards protecting our
environment we'll be asking how to
safeguard heritage buildings of which
weimar has very many whilst also
improving their climate credentials
architects planners campaigners and
scientists will be in dialogue with a
young generation of international
students
our event brings together other partner
institutions from the region to create a
hub for the new european
bauhaus here in weimar we wish good luck
to all the other event organizers across
europe each working towards change in
their region
thank you very much to ahelene and utah
and last but not least for this first
round of europe vision we moved to
cyprus to kiriaki costa hello and
greetings from brussels to youtube
[Music]
my name is dicosta and i'm joining you
from the streets of my city nicosia and
cyprus thank you for inviting us to join
you today
i am an artist and the director of
panera many 17 which is a non-profit
organization taking dedicated to social
research that is launched in 2005.
we celebrate
cypriot art study the urban and natural
landscape in our country and incorporate
local tradition in our work while
engaging our audiences to observe
contemporary culture
our main goal is to showcase the
different layers of nicosia and cypress
through the eyes of the other the local
the tourists the pacifier
we are happy to present the second part
of our project hopophilia under the
framework of the new baja european
bauhaus festival
it is a series of events focusing
on the consistence of nature and culture
in the city of nicosia
over the coming weeks
we will host workshops exhibitions
discussions and screenings inviting
visitors to change perspectives in our
city
we will see
imagining a sustainable and ecological
future together
the program
this program is cultivated with antigone
mikhail and nicolas accused
and realized in collaboration with the
municipalitar arts center the ministry
of education and the tourist board
we are looking forward to take this
journey with you and discover a new
layer of nicosia
thank you so much for joining us from
cyprus
so that was it for our first uh europe
vision around um in europe there's more
to follow but at least now we've got an
idea of the ideas and ideals that are
inspired by the new european bauhaus
project in all these european cities and
in all these european citizens but now
back to rome back to monica for the
discussion monica the floor is yours
take it away
thanks annelise thank you thank you for
this amazing tour through ideas and
values in europe so
we're so proud here in rome to open the
session of this festival of the new
european bauhaus let me just give the
floor for
an introduction for a note to president
of maxi giovanna melandri flores diors
thank you well first of all
first of all
good luck
and greetings from rome good luck to all
the venues that are connected with us
hello minister franceschini thank you
for being with us
and so so so honored
uh to welcome to maxi ursula from the
lion president of the eu commission
um
i
i
we
admire so much your strong leadership
madam president
europe is our home and europe is leading
the way
land of change of experimentation
with a green new deal
with the energy transition with a just
transition
with a human
non-extractive project for
intelli artificial intelligence
with the recent guidelines for fair
minimum wages
our firm stand i don't want to forget
this our firm stand with ukraine
for its freedom against a brutal
criminal
aggression
and
our
your
commitment to the reconstruction of
ukraine in a sustainable way
and the new european bauhaus is the soul
of this vision
let's not miss it we were discussing it
this morning
the house is burning
the crisis we are witnessing calls for
audacity and depth of vision comparable
to that fruitful and alas too short
season of last century we really must
rethink more or less everything from a
post anthropo anthropocentric point of
view
the new european bauhaus festival lands
here at maxi
a museum designed by a woman
and with the majority of women on board
in a very special time for us
and finds us in a process of deep change
we call it grand maxi greater maxi
a project inspired by the bauhaus
paradigm sustainability inclusion
innovation beauty which we want to turn
into action here
and we will
with
a very important investment thanks to
our government
um which will turn this museum into
something more together with the
ecosystem of the italian bauhaus which
is rich
and is
very much active the push toward this
evolution comes both
from the inner interdisciplinary scope
of creativity
and from global changes and challenges
from climate change to geopolitics from
the need to restore inclusion and
biodiversity to the spiritual longing
and cultural diplomacy's needs
factors that all claim
an original contribution from artistic
communities and cultural institutions
and this was your real vision madam
president for which we really thank you
so much
we know this
artists discovered the world before
there are future tellers in a way
and creative communities can help us
prototyping future worlds that's why
we're here for that's what we're here
for
beauty can be a strong power for social
change and grand maxi is
an ambitious collective exercise
architects
artists designers together with agents
from science we just discussed this
morning with environment social studies
universities and research institutions
to design regeneration patterns
together
at maxi
and this is really my final remark
we wish to be
the change we want to see in the world
reaching carbon neutrality for zaha
hadid's
architecture
which is not totally
carbon neutral today
and reaching out to those who can
transform
built environment and spatial
productions of our time and even more a
reason
to warmly welcome diabetes francis curry
2022 pritzker prize winner here today
your design with clay and wood is a
exercise we're all looking at with so
much admiration
our gaze in the last years thanks to
max's team has been searching for years
in the euromet region
in north africa lebanon and turkey the
balkans we hosted many shows of the
creative communities of these countries
and we have tried to connect the italian
and european art scene to explore
new path of co-existence so so so happy
to be able to listen to you and again
very very war welcome madam
president thank you
thank you so much giovanna milanry and
now the notice from dario franceschini
minister of culture
first of all let me thank president von
the lion for being with us today
it's an honor
italy is very proud to contribute to the
wave of creativity in the new european
house italian artists designers
architects and creatives are shaping a
more sustainable and inclusive future
where beauty meets respect for the
planet and human diversity
767 official italian party have
organized over
50 side events contributing to the
success of the festival today
madame president
i want to thank you
and to commend the work that you your
commission has done for culture
i also believe that we can and we must
do even more together to put culture at
the center of a new vision for europe
and for you relationship with the rest
of the world a vision where change
happens by design because culture offers
understanding it offers dialogue it
brings solutions combining social and
environmental commitment in short it
offers wisdom and we all know how much
we need it at this time
this is why we are inviting the
ministers of culture of the
mediterranean to meet in naples on 16th
and 17th of june and to launch with the
new institution with the member states
and with the countries from all over the
mediterranean a new process for cultural
cooperation in the region culture must
play a key role in implementing a new
agenda for the mediterranean of the
european union we want to make culture
count even more in the findings that the
eu is a force for good
for more creativity and inclusive green
societies in the mediterranean the
mediterranean is a sea of culture all
around us
we want to make full use of the power of
culture to ensure that the voice of the
eu is heard clearly on its shores and
across the world so that it brings us
closer as human beings and more united
in peace
gracie
thank you
thank you thank you mr
let me let me just tell you that it's a
great privilege discussing with you mr
mrs president and discussing with you
francis
this issue
which is an issue that has a lot to do
with our future basically we're
discussing the way we will live
the kind of society we're going to build
so president vanderlian in these three
days there will be more than 200 events
around europe we just had the taste of
this this morning so what do you expect
from that
yes so i expect a huge celebration of
the spirit of the new european bauhaus
and indeed it's amazing to see 200
events all around europe
uh more than 100 showcases in brussels
itself but you here in rome and you here
in italy you are so enthusiastic you're
so engaged you're so much the front
runners so first of all i really want to
thank you what you are doing and i hope
the camera can once go into the public
to show how packed the room is to
celebrate the new european rail house
and
what i expect is
let me a little bit explain how i see
the
role of the new european bauhaus we all
know that we are at a limit
for too many decades
we have polluted we have wasted we have
extracted
we have taken more from the planet than
we have given back
and we know there needs to be a
turnaround we know there needs to be a
change
and basically this is the european green
deal but the european green deal
has to be a lot about the climate law
legislative texts
evidence from science figures impact
assessments this is important it is the
frame we need to change
but we thought when we started the
european green deal something is missing
something is missing which is a grass
root movement by the people
and
therefore we say it is the heart and the
soul of the european green deal is the
new european bauhaus because the new
european bauhaus says we know out there
are so many initiatives so much
knowledge so much expertise you in your
arts or engineering or
other craftsmen and women
um whatever
section you're in you know so much and
you want to contribute
let's channel this in the new european
powerhouse and this is the idea behind
the new european bauhaus spirit of the
new european bauhaus
and finally what i expect also
is not only celebrate ourselves
but
look forward and say where can we
contribute better and this is the topic
of ukraine indeed we will have this
afternoon a debate with the mayor of
mario paul and ukrainian architects and
my friends
we will reconstruct ukraine
we have to do that and we will do that
and i think it is not only in our
interest it's our moral obligation to do
that but when we are reconstructing
ukraine of course owned by ukraine
let's do it in the right way let's do it
in the spirit of the new european
bauhaus and this is my message basically
to the festival let's start
to fulfill this vision and move forward
thank you incredible vision thank you so
much
i'll be back to you in a second about
ukraine and what we can do out there
even in terms of energy but uh let me
tell you that i'm a big fan of francisca
so it's quite easy to me having the
chance to talk to him not just because
he's a great architect this year the
greatest but because he has a he has a
life in a country where the discussion
with the culture nature and society can
be the basis of the future or can simply
be non-existent you decided to put it at
the center of the scene do you think
that this kind of discussions could be
useful for the future of buildings and
the way we build our structures and
future
oh
mike
okay
wow
great um
i mean i cannot start to answer without
highlighting the fact
that someone
being at the top of power take time
and invest energy to launch this idea
so
thank you for having this initiative
uh politics need to create a frame
and be a front rider
and you show it
through this mahmoud project so which
involve all europe
so the thing that
is interesting to me
and what most here
potentially don't know about it
is talking about our
neighbor
your neighbor
africa
this and now a neighbor
that is really looking to you
if you do things here great
they will copy it
if you do it wrong
they will copy it
that is
and that is why i think it's so
important that a leader just put this in
the calendar and to try to really
make this become a big big event of
course events like this helps a lot
um
she is not
dealing simply with the political deals
i love the fact that you said we're
going to create loyal
lao and whatever frame to allow that
kind of ideas happen
and those events are places where you
could share and we could talk we see
that it's coming from really the very
top because she has the power to do it
and she could haven't done it you have
many many people that pass before her
and we haven't seen that initiative to
tackle these big challenges that we are
facing climate change and so again thank
you to you
um i think that it shows that we are
together if you just start to do like in
a little
corner by your own
it is good but this meeting today will
this launching of this bauhaus new
bauhaus will create a strong impact and
however you do
in that kind of meetings if you show
examples if you let people know that
using renewable materials and energy you
know neutral material
should be our future should help shape
our future then you really convincing
people see it is in the political
calendar is not like
paying lips
services but it is a big concern so that
why i think that kind of gathering are
important
thank you thank you so very much so
not just a slogan or a headline but a
change
president of the line uh you just
mentioned ukraine and you gave us this
incredible vision but nevertheless new
european bauhaus is the let's say
cultural dimension to the added to the
green deal
do you think that uh
what we're going through this war in
ukraine will have an impact or
is a good reason for a stop
in this process
or we have to move forward anyway
yeah if francis carrera just said it if
we get it wrong
you'll copy if we get it right
you'll copy so we have to get it right
also with this atrocious war
and there is a paradox happening right
now
because you know that um the russian
economy is basically based on fossil
fuels it's oil it's coal it's gas and we
are heavily depending
in the european union on
these fossil fuels
because of this horrible war
that putin has unleashed against ukraine
we have decided
to get rid of our dependency on russian
fossil fuels that's good
get rid of our dependency on any fossil
fuels that's good now we have to get it
right
and
it is not easy because in the short term
we have to diversify away from russia to
other reliable suppliers but we have to
be very careful
that we are not locked in with the new
suppliers
that replace for example gas but that we
immediately move on
to renewable energy
so to invest massively into sun into
wind into hydropower into hydrogen you
name it
and this is now the task for all of us
in the european union to really move
forward and show the way with renewables
what what is reassuring for me is to see
the initiatives in europe for example a
few weeks ago i was
at a so-called wind summit in denmark
where four member states said we
together in the north sea will create a
wind park
that when we're done with our goals
is able
to supply the energy for 50 million
homes in the european union just by wind
the whole energy consumption
or solar strategy to really move forward
in that
so
we are at a watershed moment also not
only geopolitically but also uh in in
view of the european green deal there is
a second dimension
we have started the so-called renovation
wave because we should not forget that
40 percent of our co2 emissions
come from buildings heating and cooling
40 percent that's a lot but it's also an
opportunity to change a lot to improve a
lot
and there comes in of course the built
environment all those who are dealing
with the built environment have a
responsibility now we invest more than
50 billion euros but of course we need
not only the investment we need your
expertise your knowledge your ideas your
innovation behind it to really make it
sustainable
and here i wish
you would have been with me this morning
in the academy the pontifical academy
to see the slideshow of francis carey
it was breathtaking
to see what he has created
as schools hospitals houses parliaments
museums
all nature based solutions
so natural material clay and wood and
straw and wool as you know better than
me
with an incredible beauty
because what did he do he copied nature
and what can be more beautiful than
nature itself and more scientific than
nature itself so
you're really a frontrunner i'm amazed
frances
thank you so much
and
[Music]
francis now i'm afraid
after this endorsement i'm afraid you
got to give us a little bit of your
vision what drives you when you think of
a building
a building that can be
far away in a jungle or in a remote
place or it can become also a big
building somewhere in an urban context
give us your vision
no
okay i mean wow
um when i step out from the aircraft
this morning i was almost dying for
sleep
and then i came i met um so
to the odm audience um and then also it
was like so much energy in the room and
now i'm cooking because it's even more
energy in the room you know
um
and so the theme is so important to now
it's about being resilient you know i
mean um
so we have big concerns
it has been said
but i mean if we want to let a better
world for our kids
we have to go another way i'm sure is
not just the politician and not just the
architect it is everyone here
um everyone in his profession but
everyone as human
and the big problem with facing if you
start
it's not easy people may not understand
but it's also important to stand
if you stand look at me you know i'm
coming from a little tiny village
and when i have these shows to access
education in germany i came for um you
know
a training 18 month training
and
you know honestly i discovered the
potential in this country is not just
the food and not just that if you work
you get paid you had access to education
so i just grabbed it and i did it i went
back to burkina start to work now i'm
building and i would recommend everyone
to be resilient have a vision really
work hard for it don't really follow the
fashion if you do that everyone is doing
the same but follow
you know the way you could just use your
skills to serve humanity i will always
say we all deserve quality
and that is important no matter where we
are
and then we all can contribute to create
this we should not wait and that way i
like that kind of discussion it allowed
us to understand that the leader are
open for that and then we are all in one
boat you know
it is the mother planet it's our only
home
if we just destroy it by
exploiting it it
by
using
fossil energy at to the end but where
should we go i know that some people are
trying to get a rocket and travel to
up
but to the moon
then i think it is also good that a lot
of us
get together and really dare to change
this planet and make it a better place
thank you
thank you
thank you
such an important message
[Applause]
obviously you're stressing this idea of
european green deal and europe has the
means to reach it 2030 2050
there's also another side of this issue
which is the social side of it being
sustainable on a social
level
when it comes to europe and when it
comes to other countries like african
countries that have a much worse
financial or economic situation so how
can you keep the two sides together the
social sustainability and the ability to
get to the
result
so whatever we do in the european wing
green deal we
[Music]
look at the principle of europe
we have in europe the social market
economy and it's based on the principle
that yes there
is investment and
benefits and prosperity but we have to
make sure that everyone is takes part in
it no one is left behind and the same is
for the european green deal
this transformation is huge and we know
that vulnerable households or smallest
businesses have little room to maneuver
so in whatever we do from the legal
perspective in the european green deal
comes along with a social element in it
be it a just transition fund for regions
that have to go a longer way forward to
reach our goals or be it the social
climate fund we are just debating in
parliament and the council
to compensate with the high energy
prices actually created through fossil
fuels gas prices
that we can compensate vulnerable
households and smallest businesses to
really go along with us this long way of
transformation
but this in a broader sense also
translate to our neighborhood
and our neighbor africa
the two of us
like in any neighborhood if we do it
together we're going to be stronger and
do it better
and what i said initially that
we are
leaving behind the fossil fuels
of course also says we are going into
the renewables and if i look at our
neighbors in africa
you have the resources for renewable
energy in abundance what wind is
concerned what sun is concerned but also
hydropower
the preconditions for hydrogen
so we've understood
that together with our neighbors
we if we do it right we develop the
renewable energies that will fuel in a
positive climate-friendly way
uh the future of this planet and
therefore the investment
is very much geared towards that we call
the investment global gateway
150 billion euros that are just
designed for
doing this transformation together
establishing the new form of energy we
will have
and working on on these new paths
together with each other
and here i think
another principle is important which i
learned during the pandemic in the
pandemic it was extremely difficult
and we started to learn yes in the short
term perhaps you have to bring
vaccines to the continent
but what you really have to make sure is
that the technology for producing
vaccines is established in africa that's
what we do right now or the same now
with the food crisis we are facing
perhaps in the short term you have to
bring food but
what you have to do in parallel is
establish the technologies in on the
continent for example for precision
farming for nanotechnologies for
fertilizers so completely new
technologies for a drier age so that in
africa itself is the technology to
produce what is necessary and this goes
also of course for the renewables in the
european green deal only together will
we be successful and we want to
rediscover the power of africa again
this idea of
that's amazing because this idea of
being together of working together
including people and countries it's it's
at the basis of all these initiatives
and
francisca if you have to look at the
future in terms of architecture
what could you spot out as the key
elements
and what are the mistakes the big
mistakes that have been done and
shouldn't be done again
okay um i mean it's always easy to point
out what has been done wrong or to
accuse people
but i think here is a general situation
um i mean
our big enemy is our
inability
really to change
so
what we do is to pretend if we preserve
the situation cold
and we make some cosmetic changes
um then we are sustainable or we have
good buildings i mean this is now the
situation we know that we need to be
much more strong i don't want to say
radical but
sort of
if not
there will not be progress and that what
i see is one of the
you know the issue that has been that is
still now a big problem in the past
we believe in technology we are thinking
with technology in construction field uh
with very modern material new materials
um you know we
we we're going to make it but it has
proven wrong let me go back and take a
special
um which has been called like wow uh the
new the modern material that we could
use um sno from germany that is the
place where uh um i live and see
you have to replace all of these because
it made people sick
and it costs a lot of resources so we
have to really be careful and think for
the long term
really what is really good for us for
our future
and then go ahead those are things that
i think should not be done again but
again
in gatherings like this i think
i'm not the one that will say negative
and negative we have to make sure that
we say hey look at
look at
that is the big hope you know if someone
like me that just came from a little
place
really um
consider that in his dna you know
working with nature
trying to see how i can take a material
that is available in the place and use
it in the best smart way
can be on stage with a
president of sula it's showing us that
is
optimism a lot of optimism that is what
we have to spread is not too late but
it's important to know about it and
start to fight for it not what i think
i see the future
not too late
not too late but let's start to fight
for it before handing back to to
brussels this class were
this is a platform for change do you
remember the day that you decided to
launch this initiative
why you said okay this is going to be
the new european market was
two years ago in the state of the union
the speech for the state of the union
and there we had started already
so now i'm three years in the mandate so
we had started the european green deal
actually 100 day after taking office
then the pandemic hit so
there was a lot going on but as i said
initially
i had the idea the soul the heart is
missing and this was the moment when i
realized you need this bottom-up
movement from the people for the people
and this is the new european bauhaus
thank you it has been a privilege being
with you francis thank you president on
the alliance go ahead you wanted
annalise just a second because francisca
wanted to add one word so no just to say
thank you for organizing all of these
and i i love italy i mean i've been
teaching it i love italy
and then i of course i love rome and i
love milan we're doing now with
australia vodo and uh and stefano bowery
we're doing the trionale uh in milan
it's about uh now unknown announce uh
which is like
a you know
a way to explore
what we ignore and there's a lot about
it what we ignore
and i'm thinking about the positive
thing europe has energy and if you use
it we can inspire you the world but if
we keep stacking like this
it will it won't work great
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you again president for the lion
analyzer super sorry this was out of
program but you know people come to
italy and they say they love italy you
know it happens so this is life so back
to you back to your brother says
annelise well what's not to love in
italy and in rome of course monica thank
you so much for the stimulating
conversation but i would like to invite
all of you to brussels too there's much
to love here too
also i love the idea of putting the
bauhaus in an international context a
wider international context reaching out
to our neighbors
now um there's someone here well not
here who wanted to be here but who
really appreciates the new european
bauhaus concept and idea and who wanted
to share her enthusiasm
for this initiative it's roberta mitzola
the president of the european parliament
and she sent us this video message
dear festival goers and participants
the new european bauhaus initiative was
like its 20th century predecessor
designed to address the contemporary
challenges facing our societies
created as a part of the eu's green deal
it aims to unite the arts with science
and technology a combination with which
we can create a more sustainable future
culture plays such a strong role in our
lives it shapes our values our
characters and our identities so as our
sustainability as ambitions increase
further they must be aligned with our
investment in arts and culture
this is why it is so important to
celebrate festivals like this one
festivals where people across the
continent get to engage with content
that calls to our minds senses and
hearts
this festival is just the start of many
projects that will link citizens of
europe with the green deal our
principals are committed to keeping you
the people of europe at the center of
our agenda and we hope that you will
rediscover your urban landscapes and
embrace the environmentally friendly
developments i hope that you benefit
from the co-creative spaces that will be
available for the next four days whether
you are joining in online or in person
know that everyone is welcome included
and encouraged to work together
whether you are an engineer a student an
artist or anyone who believes in a
durable and efficient future future join
us in celebrating a new creative
movement
roberta mitzola's message
we've been hopping around the european
continent and there's much more to see
so i suggest we continue our journey and
we move on to bulgaria to kiril walchev
kirill greetings from brussels
hello from sofia i'm kiriyo valchef i am
director general bulgarian news agency
bta
today bta puts out more 10 000 news
items and 3
000 photos daily from bulgaria and
abroad
bta is one of
oldest news agencies in the world our
first
news was published
on uh in
1998
in
1960 bta moved
here in
this new home uh called the palace of
journalism it was designed by architect
evgeny zidarov
and was among the most modern buildings
in sofia as an official
uh partner of initiative new european
bauhaus bta is organizing today a hybrid
site event the discussion is about the
transformation of bta building and the
environment in front of bta within the
values of bauhaus as beautiful
sustainable and inclusive
we make exhibition of ideas and
conceptual projects how students from
our partners forest university and
university of architecture in sofia see
transformation and you can see
great ideas behind me among the
evergreen plants to make water walls and
spheres with holographics of remarkable
buildings from countries from where bta
broadcasts news to make an information
wave on the facet to which to hide the
air conditioners and also to turn the
roof into a garden with cafeteria we
hope to find more partners part of
bauhaus initiative to turn our building
into a bta house
thank you
thank you very much kirill and through
the wonders of technology we swiftly
move to latvia to zen loka hello from
brussels
thank you mission hello to everyone my
name is
and i am sending you greetings from
latvia we apply a city which is situated
at the baltic sea and is also known as
the city where the wind is born
latvian association of local and
regional governments is joining the
festival new european
side buffalo devoted global education
with the title make a wish creative
places of learning and growing together
for better global future
the event is taking place today and we
have already spent the first part of day
in discussions on different places and
ways of learning tort retailing in
libraries creative activities in
international americans for children and
youth as well as the role of documentary
films in promoting from egypt in society
and now
we are fully into the creation of the
wish tree garden near the gymnasium
in leopard as the wishes is the basis
for a beautiful future we are creating
together
thank you and see you
bauhaus ideas in action in latvia thank
you for that and on to romania hello
valentine murasin greetings from
brussels
i'm actually christina potra mureshan
saying hello from romania timisoara
we are here at greenfield uh
in the midst of our community gardens
and uh are happy to connect both locally
and remotely to other people who care
about nature and
about our future together
right now
the youngsters are having a calligraphy
workshop practicing to create messages
that are
meaningful and also beautiful
while
over here
we are in the process of preparing a
sustainable picnic with focus on local
and um
seasonal products and also on reducing
waste
um actually over the next three days uh
there will be all sorts of activities
happening from tending to the beehives
to
a kids gardening workshop to building an
insect hotel and lots of running and
cycling
tonight our partners from
liberty marathon will organize a
training run
connecting the western university
community garden to greenfield
the two locations that are part of the
healthy places project which is a
finalist at this year's neb prizes
tomorrow there will be another run
uh that will celebrate 11 years of
allerg a local
amateur runners club and also a great
community of volunteers
we even have a
satellite event happening in italy in
sardinia organized by our friends and
partners from chita de la terrace
so as you can see we are a large and
diverse community and
we are all the happier now uh to feel
part of the
of the neb family
and um i would like to conclude by
saying that
we are looking forward to all the
activities happening in brussels and
elsewhere during the neb festival
thank you so very much and moving from
the east to the west we go to sonia
garcia freile in spain greetings from
brussels
we work for the inclusion of people with
disabilities and through the sala
computer center the exhibition place we
are aligned with the new european
households it's sustainable because by
considering accessibility from the
beginning the cost is minimal
it's inclusive because the space and the
contents are fully accessible the
exhibiting artists have disabilities and
we collaborate with in the labor
inclusion of these artists facilitating
their access to the art market and
because we contribute to the elimination
of prejudices about artistic creation by
people with disabilities and it's
beautiful because accessibility does not
imply ugliness a well implemented
accessibility is the one that it's
perceived because it has been
successfully integrated we are in the
sala cambia de centido
a space where disability is the
protagonist
either because the
exhibiting artists have disabilities or
because disability has inspired the work
exhibited the exhibition i'm showing
it's from the artist angel baltazar
and its name exodus romerias made up of
7 pieces and it can be visited today and
tomorrow morning here at the
headquarters of the foundation in madrid
during the festival but also until the
end of august we hope to see you all and
you are accordingly invaded thank you so
much thank you in spain and on to the
czech republic where we will be landing
what have you going on david khorak and
greetings from brussels by the way
then hello everyone my name is david
severa and i come from a beautiful
wonderful student town of brno just now
the weather is not so nice it's live so
it's raining cats and dogs but we are in
the process of an event called second
home uh sharing the city our event's
goal is to connect people who are
interested in the way we live since we
spent more than half of our lives in
these shared public spaces for example
schools public squares cafes and
everything we try to connect as many
people who are interested in these
topics together so they can figure out
better ways to improve our other way we
live we co-organized the event with
faculty of architecture so we have a
better bit of
impact on the architecture and urbanism
as well and just now i am being covered
by a new european bauhaus project sort
of it's a plastic it's it's from plastic
guys and it's from upcycle plug stick
and it's really saving the event since
it started really really raining we are
having a networking session in the
progress so i'm just going to show you a
bit of the people hiding
hiding before the rain and these are our
creatives who are discussing the
possibilities how to improve public
spaces we believe that european house
for us is about continuous dialogue
about connecting people from different
squares we are creative hub so we
decided to
put our creatives in work and try to
involve them on the process of forming a
wonderful time thank you and hope the
weather is better wherever you are see
you it is better here uh thank you to
the bad boys in bruno and to all the
others of course
and so um this is the end of our
sampling of what's going on in different
uh european countries in the context of
the bauhaus festival but let's get back
to rome for one last time monika it was
a pleasure to share the stage with you
an honor to in my case um and to
hear you talk with your guests i hope
you enjoyed our um tour de rop our
vision of europe
annelise it has been amazing we were all
here clapping and laughing sometimes and
you gave us an incredible energy so i
think this is the basic message thank
you on behalf of everyone here in maxi
again president on the line francisca
milano and everybody in the room and
thanks for what you're doing in these
incredible days of the festival and good
luck for that thank you bye
bye-bye
and thank you to to your guests
and to your hosting the event in rome by
rome for now
so ladies and gentlemen online we are
leaving you now for
approximately a quarter of an hour and
then we will be back with more so don't
go off too far see you soon see you back
here at the garmadi team in
15 minutes
[Music]
i see you
[Music]
[Music]
you